what do they want revenge
they're using her to get to me
Jennifer Lopez back in action
when you sign on to be an actress and
resign yourself to the fact like I'm
gonna go all the way or I'm not gonna
take the role the Secret's out
yeah say no more for fans of the Triple
Threat after a string of rom-coms I'll
marry you
you
is it time for dinner JLo's taking a
break from meat cutes in the mother you
burn down our entire world
for her yes
and these fight moves well they are
giving serious Vibes of her 2002 flick
enough it's one good hit
and it's over
[Music]
oh he bleeds whenever you Empower
yourself physically mentally and
emotionally you're empowering yourself
too it's almost an animal thing for you
from here on you do everything I say
you're driving I'm 12. let's go
let's forward 20 years Jen's an assassin
protecting her daughter from bad guys I
hate it here I want to go home not till
you know how to survive everything it
takes you're scaring me every time I
look at you I'm scared the movie drops
on Netflix May 12th another way to
remember yeah it's also Mother's Day
Lavelle when Hector Alvarez are still
out there you and I both know the only
way you protect that child is to
disappear
you're not getting away this time
so what's next for Jen she's moving on
from throwing punches
to a collab with hubby Ben Affleck
following the Oscar Winner's latest
movie got a name for it which tells the
backstory of Michael Jordan's iconic
shoe line Air Jordan I don't know
seriously no maybe it'll grow on me is
it true that Jennifer helped you
understand the Fashions of that era and
yeah you know I mean the listen it's
brilliant and helps me in every
conceivable way and this this whole
process really has been a a
collaboration we're just getting rolling
to do uh the story of a wrestler named
Anthony Robles who was born with one leg
and won a national championship I just
felt like him too far to lose yes I
believe uh Jennifer Lopez may be doing
that I'm gonna be it I'm gonna make it
look like she's just doing as a favor to
me but actually she is what can
what can well until this family affair
hits our screens we'll enjoy watching a
locked and loaded Lopez I'm a killer
but I'm also
also